We can find additional information to describe
the shape of an object by looking at its perimeter,
by looking at its boundary.
Here we have a very simple scene with a dark
object against a white background. The simplest
way to compute the length of the perimeter
of the object is to simply trace around the
outside of the object. So the lines are either
vertical or horizontal, and this is a technique
called crack coding. We measure the length
of this blue path. It tells us something about
the length of the perimeter of the object.
Another way of measuring the perimeter of
the object is to first of all consider all
of the pixels that sit on the edge of the
object, and those pixels are all marked with
a red dot. Those red dots are the centres
of the pixels that are on the edge of the
object. And an alternative technique is to
join the centres of the dots. This is called
an 8-neighbor chain code. So the length of
this path can be considered to be the length
of the boundary of the object.
We can see that there are going to be some
differences here. The crack code is perhaps
going to overestimate the boundary of the
object. The chain code is going to perhaps
underestimate the boundary of the object,
but the chain code does a much better job
when the object has got sides that are neither
vertical nor horizontal. When there are sloped
segments on the object, chain code can perhaps
give a slightly more realistic estimate.
In this case with very small objects the difference
between the two approaches is going to be
quite significant. When objects are very large
with hundreds or thousands of pixels, the
difference is much less significant.
Now if we compute the perimeter using either
of the techniques just mentioned, and we call
that the perimeter length p, we can compute
a measure that we call circularity and this
is a measure that is related to compactness.
So we take 4x π, multiplied by the area of
the object, which comes from the zeroth moment,
and we divide it by the perimeter squared.
So this is a non-dimensional quantity. The
numerator contains the area, which has got
units of pixels squared. We divided by the
length, which has got units of pixels squared.
So this non-dimensional quantity has got no
units.
For the case of the circle, circularity has
got a value of 1 … 1 means it’s a circle.
For less than 1 it means that it’s not a
circle, and for a long line it approaches
0, so it cannot be bigger than 1, it can be
less than 1. 1 if it’s a circle.